einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu heute live ein jahr
corona in deutschland jedenfalls und wir
stellen uns die frage wie sieht's aus
aktuell in der situation vor allem in
der pflege
was herrschen dort für verhältnisse wie
schlimm ist die lage was läuft okay was
muss besser werden und was machen
vielleicht auch andere länder besser als
wir das sind die fragen die wir uns
heute abend stellen und ihr könnt
natürlich wie immer gerne mit
diskutieren und auch kommentieren fragen
stellen da stets nochmal pflege im
dauerstress dass also das thema die
adresse wie immer seht ihr unten
eingeblendet und hier nochmal der
aufrufe euch gerne zu beteiligen wir
sprechen später mit professor michael
isfort vom deutschen institut für
angewandte pflegeforschung in köln
schauen aber zunächst auf die praxis und
zwar in hamburg dort arbeitet genau
genommen in der asklepios klinik
wandsbek lars siegel auf der
intensivstation
dass wir uns vor der sendung darauf
geeinigt dass wir uns duzen das nehme
ich sie gerne an ich als christopher und
die frage nicht wir jetzt zunächst mal
die zahlen heute sind ja rückläufig kann
man daraus folgern dass bei euch auf der
intensivstation so etwas wie entspannung
langsam entsteht oder wäre das ein
falscher schluss in christopher vielen
dank erstmal für die einladung und dass
ich mich hier auch dazu äußern kann
ja die zahlen rückläufig begrüßen das
glaube ich alle gesellschaftlich wie wir
auch in der pflege die maßnahmen
scheinen auch zu greifen
wobei man natürlich vorsichtig sein
müssen wir hatten ja schon ein paar
wellen erlebt wo man wo wir mal ein paar
mehr patienten und weniger patienten
hatten gerade auch mit kroner infektion
und derzeit sind unsere kapazitäten noch
nicht ausgeschöpft also wir können immer
noch patienten aufnehmen und das ist
unsere derzeitige situation auf station
damit unsere zuschauer unsere user auch
mal einen eindruck davon bekommen wie
das genau aussieht auf deiner station
während deiner arbeit hat mein kollege
ist anne rieken dich mal begleitet und
das schauen wir uns gerne noch mal
gemeinsam an
mitten in der nacht geht es der frau
plötzlich schlechter sie lag schon mit
dem krankenhaus jetzt muss sie auf die
intensivstation intensivpfleger das
siegel ist mit dem isolierzimmer zwölf
betten können sie vom rest der station
abtrennen funkgeräte sind der kontakt
nach draußen
die patientin hat viel zu wenig
sauerstoff im blut überhaupt hier bei
uns ist noch mal und ich glaube jetzt
versteht sie langsam dass wir halt da
wirklich einmal intensiver auf sie drauf
gucken müssen
ein besonders tückisches merkmal von
kogit 19
die patienten fühlen sich noch bis
zuletzt ziemlich fit die frau kann noch
sprechen und sogar gut atmen dass der
körper sie lange kompensieren kann und
dann vielleicht gar nicht gemerkt dass
es einem so richtig schlecht geht so
aber dann kann man wenn man pech hat
kommt dann irgendwann der keb punkt und
dann wird sein halt kritisch das siegel
schaut bei seinen patienten
er kümmert sich zurzeit um einen fast
genesen den patienten ein junger mann
den sie mit der sauerstoffmaske wieder
fit bekommen haben so wie es aussieht
kann er die intensivstation bald
verlassen
solche erfolge sind es diese hier
durchhalten lassen
trotz der dauerhaften grund an spannen
lassen beginn des beitrags war von
patienten die rede die offenbar noch gar
nicht glauben können dass ihnen ein
schwerer verlauf womöglich bevorsteht
die noch atmen können die noch sich
artikulieren können für wie türkisch
hältst du die krankheit oder wie kommt
ihr das in deinem alltag vor
ja also das ist wirklich ein phänomen
was wir jetzt gerade auch in der zweiten
welle sehen dass wir patienten haben die
positiv auf kobe 19 getestet werden ins
krankenhaus kommen weil sie sich nicht
gut fühlen dann gibt es diesen positiven
test und eigentlich noch gar nicht so
richtig verstehen was jetzt daran so
schlimm es weiterhin einigermaßen doch
gut geht und sie auch sich ganz normal
mit uns verständigen können und und auf
einmal kann aber dieser verlauf ganz
kritisch werden also dieser wir sehen
das an den blutwerten dass der
sauerstoff schon im blut
sehr gering ist das merkt der patient
anfangs noch nicht außer er ist
natürlich vor krank mit
lungenerkrankungen wie zum beispiel copd
und da muss man den patienten auch erst
einmal ein bisschen überzeugen dass es
wirklich notwendig ist dass wir diesen
diese intensiven maßnahmen machen denn
wir haben schon gesehen dass diese
verläuft sehr kritisch auf einmal werden
und wir patienten dann auch beatmen
müssen und pflegerisch und medizinisch
so intervenieren müssen dass wir sie zum
beispiel wie man die bilder gesehen hat
auf dem bauch drehen müssen und das über
mehrere tage und wochen
wie ist dein eindruck von der
altersverteilung deiner patienten also
mit den schweren verläufen da heißt es
ja eigentlich immer dass die erst ab
einem bestimmten alter hauptsächlich
kommen kannst du das bestätigen
ja also die genauen zahlen habe ich
natürlich nicht aber es ist klar dass
ältere und vor erkrankte patienten
natürlich gefährdet da sind durch das
kobe 19 virus und dann wahrscheinlich
einen schweren verlauf haben aber wir
haben auch häufig junge menschen gesehen
auch ich bin selber 35 auch patienten
die jünger sind als ich die sehr
kritisch waren und zum teil auch bad mit
werden mussten und lange bei uns auf
intensivstationen verwalter eine woche
und länger bis es ihnen wieder gut ging
also man kann nicht nur sagen dass es
nur patienten trifft die die älter und
stadtbau erkrankt sind also es kann
genauso gut auch junge und nicht vor
krank der patienten treffen und auch
schwer treffen
ja das ist auf jeden fall auch noch mal
ein wichtiger hinweis du hast dich
selbst gerade angesprochen dass 35 wir
haben im beitrag auch gesehen da werden
sehr viele maßnahmen ergriffen damit ihr
euch eben schützen könnt ihr redet
miteinander zum beispiel über funkgerät
und versucht wirklich da die isolation
so gut es geht eben aufrechtzuerhalten
wie groß ist trotzdem da eine sorge die
ich selbst anzustecken
also meine persönliche sorge hält sich
ehrlich gesagt in grenzen
wir haben unsere schutzmaßnahmen die wir
auch strikt einhalten herget mal bei uns
auf station da konnte es ja mit leben
und ich kann jetzt nicht sagen dass es
am anfang genauso war am anfang der
erste coup patienten nehme ich mich noch
ganz genau wie ich vor seiner tür stand
man kannte es feuer erst aus dem
fernsehen und auf einmal ist ein patient
da der genau dieses virus hat und am
anfang war alles noch ein wenig mystisch
wie überträgt sich das wie ist der
verlauf dieses los da hatte man schon
natürlich angst und wenn ich jetzt vor
mir persönlich spreche ich natürlich
auch und aber jetzt haben wir ja das
erste jacob hohner hinter uns wären
viele maßnahmen ergriffen auch bei uns
auf station wie zb die walkie talkies
sodass wir auch immer kontakt nach außen
halten können wenn wir etwas brauchen
also wir müssen uns nicht sehr oft an
und ausziehen und damit uns vielleicht
eventuell kontaminieren
und ich denke diese maßnahmen sind jetzt
so gut dass ich persönlich gerade keine
angst habe mich auf arbeit an group bei
kubi anzustecken
ich denke wenn man jetzt zb ein
supermarkt geht weiß man nicht wer
vielleicht erkrankt ist oder nicht und
wie auf stationen durch die
isolationsmaßnahmen wissen wer erkrankt
ist und wer nicht unser thema ist ja die
jahresbilanz das ist natürlich ein
weites feld wenn man jetzt auf ein
komplettes jahr zurück schaut trotzdem
würde mich mal interessieren was ist dir
aufgefallen im verlauf dieses jahres was
ist aus deiner sicht in der pflege
besonders vielleicht positiv gelaufen
was empfindest du auch in seiner arbeit
immer als positiv oder zumindest öfter
und was bemängelt du vor allem
also was ich sagen muss dieses jahr ist
sehr schnell vergangen wir wurden ja so
ein bisschen überrascht ja von diesem
virus wie ist dann auf einmal auch zu
uns gekommen ist und am anfang war
natürlich alles immer noch so ein
bisschen unsicher wir haben von anfang
an strikte isolationsmaßnahmen getroffen
aber das musste sich natürlich erstmal
alles einspielen gerade bei der masse
der patienten die später zu uns gekommen
sind und im verlauf des jahres muss man
schon sagen dass positiv zu sehen ist
dass wir auch diese maßnahmen wie das
walkie talkie zum beispiel dass man sich
hat sachen einfallen lassen von
stationen vom vom krankenhaus an sich
die uns die arbeit damit erleichtern
auch mit den regulierungsmaßnahmen und
was man auch gemerkt hat in dieser zeit
dass dieser zusammenhalt im team sehr
wichtig ist und dass janne und da hat
man auch gemerkt dass er zusammenhalt
sehr stark ist und bei uns auf
intensivstationen ich kann jetzt nur
davon sprechen ist ja auch die
hierarchie ebene sehr sehr klein so dass
wir wie du uns alle und wir arbeiten
alle hand und hand und das war auch im
zwischenmenschlichen muss man sagen das
war ein schönes jahr
zwischenmenschlich unter uns die dort
arbeiten wir sprechen gleich über
wertschätzung
das ist offenbar also ein aspekt
jedenfalls dieser wertschätzung das
zwischenmenschliche hast du angesprochen
das ist gegeben
wir gucken auch immer parallel hier
natürlich auf unsere user und die
zuschriften unterschied zum beispiel
viel kleines über youtube das gehalt
welches banker bekommen sollten die
pflege erhalten aber da sieht man mal
wieder das geld wichtiger ist als der
mensch das lassen jetzt erst mal so
stehen aber wir wollen natürlich gleich
auch noch mal auf die finanziellen
aspekte auch da eines jobs zu sprechen
kommen die wertschätzung also der pflege
das ist ja seit vielen jahren ein thema
in corona zeiten wurde da ja doch auch
der eine oder andere missstand noch mal
besonders deutlich vor augen geführt und
wir wollen uns da auch noch mal einige
details anschauen
pflegekräfte in der pandemie jeden tag
haben sie ein erhöhtes ansteckungsrisiko
das leiden vor augen auch den tod eine
große emotionale belastung und weil
personal fehlt haben sie an den extrem
hohen arbeitseinsatz
es gab applaus und respekt aber was gibt
es finanziell für pflegerinnen und
pfleger helfer in der krankenpflege
verdienen mindestens 2500 90 euro
fachkräfte 3400 euro
im vergangenen jahr wurde für den
öffentlichen dienst eine tariferhöhung
geschlossen in der pflege um 8,7 prozent
in der intensivpflege um zehn prozent
außerdem gibt es eine corona prämie von
maximal 600 euro
allerdings sind die meisten
krankenhäuser nicht in kommunaler hand
sondern privatwirtschaftlich organisiert
oder in kirchlicher trägerschaft für
krankenhäuser mit besonders vielen cupid
patienten beschloss der bund zusätzliche
hilfen von 100 millionen euro heißt rund
1000 euro pro kopf für pflegepersonal
die länder können aufstocken nach
angaben der gewerkschaft verdi erhalten
den bonus aber nur etwa 100.000
pflegekräfte lediglich ein viertel der
pflegerinnen und pfleger in
krankenhäusern
auch wenn die belastung für die
allermeisten zugenommen hat die
belastung hat zugenommen von der politik
gab es eben auch die ankündigung es sind
ja auch zahlungen getätigt worden
ohne jetzt da bei euch aufs detail gehen
zu wollen aber kann man sagen
davon ist auch was bei euch in hamburg
angekommen also wenn ich jetzt vom hier
spreche da ist auch was angekommen von
den ausgezahlten boni und das ist halt
ein teil der wertschätzung und ich
glaube der andere grosse teil ist
natürlich wir brauchen mehr pflegekräfte
john wurzeln schreibt uns er selbst sei
auch pfleger und arbeite an der
anerkennung seines jobs im ausland und
im eu raum besonders in deutschland sei
an einer guten pflege keiner
interessiert empfindest du das auch so
wie ist dein gefühl
die wertschätzung was ist gerade
angesprochen also ich persönlich mache
meinen beruf sehr gerne und ich habe
denen jetzt auch nicht ausgewählt weil
ich von der ich sage jetzt einfach von
der gesellschaft anerkennung mir
gewünscht hat man hat natürlich gemerkt
dass und auch bei mir selber bevor ich
im krankenhaus gearbeitet hat man hat
nicht über dieses system der des
krankenhauses oder der medizinischen
betreuung nachgedacht wenn man die hilfe
braucht ich glaube dann wird einem
bewusst was man oder wie dieser apparat
funktioniert und wie wichtig das für uns
als gesellschaft ist dass wir ein gutes
gesundheitssystem haben und ich glaube
daran hakt einfach ein bisschen dass das
pflegerische medizinische etwas im
hintergrund gebiet oder jetzt der zeit
ist wir lesen gerade noch ein paar
kommentare vorhop von oder über youtube
die pflegekräfte sollten endlich fair
bezahlt werden die politik macht immer
nur leere versprechen also so ganz
stimmt das jetzt nach unseren
erkenntnissen nicht also man könnte mit
sicherheit immer noch fragen ob mehr
getan werden muss aber immerhin ein teil
ist zumindest auch bei euch in hamburg
angekommen
die pflegekräften kräfte leisten enormes
schreibt dieses ist gegen auch über
youtube das war schon vor der krise so
jetzt kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
wie das ein mensch noch bewältigen kann
mit dieser großen zusatzbelastung damit
auch die frage an dich wie bewältigt man
das was motiviert dich jeden tag wieder
alles zu geben diese sehr sehr
fordernden zeit also als erstes
motivierte mich natürlich dass wir in
einem guten team arbeiten
die arbeit macht mir auch wenn das sich
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch anhört
die machen wir natürlich auch spaß ich
mache meine arbeit gerne und wir haben
es hört sich vielleicht dazu an
von außen wir haben ja nicht nur
negative erlebnisse auf station also
natürlich die menschen die zu uns kommen
dann geht es ja schlecht sind kritisch
krank aber die positive erlebnisse sind
ja wenn wir den patienten so weit helfen
können dass sie unsere station verlassen
und wir zählen zum einen auch von
briefen die wir erhalten die wir auch
jetzt in kronau zeiten erhalten haben
wir herrn davon dass patienten uns auf
besuchen kommen die vielleicht auch noch
nicht laufen konnten als er unsere
station verlassen haben und es dann zu
fuß mit familie besuchen kommt was er
zurzeit leider nicht möglich ist und
auch von solchen erlebnissen profitieren
werden das sind die positiven aspekte
eines berufs wenn jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz auf die downside sozusagen schauen
du hast gerade auch angesprochen
es ist zum einen die bezahlung da ist
jetzt was passiert ist zum anderen aber
auch eben der personalschlüssel
wie ist da deine einschätzung tut sich
da was was müsste konkret da vielleicht
noch mehr passieren was würdest du dir
wünschen zumindest mal für deine station
also ich habe das glück dass ich auf
einer station arbeite wo die
stellensituation sehr gut aussieht wie
sind sehr gut besetzt wir haben auch
immer wieder bewerber die gerne zu uns
auf stadt zu möchten und bei uns gern
tätig sein wollen es ist glaub mir jetzt
ein schritt der personal untergrenzen wo
gesetzlich limitiert wurde wie viele
patienten der fliehkraft betreuen darf
und ich denke das ist ja ein schritt in
die richtige richtung
die frage wird gerade noch an mich
herangetragen
wir haben das auch hier bei uns bei
unseren usern gerade gehört ob du deine
berufswahl jemals bereut hast also nach
allem was ich jetzt bis jetzt von dir
gehört habe machst du nicht den eindruck
also ich persönlich beweise nicht und
ich habe auch vorher auch schon was
anderes gemacht ich hab mal metallberuf
gelernt ich habe schon mal angefangen zu
studieren und bin eigentlich nur durch
zufall ins krankenhaus gekommen durch
meinen zivildienst was ich übrigens wenn
ich die äußerungen tätigen darf sehr
begrüßen würde wenn es sowas wiedergebe
wie soziales jahr oder
auf einer gesetzlichen ebene und nur so
bin ich überhaupt in diesem beruf
gekommen und er hat mir schon immer spaß
gemacht und ich wird auch nichts anderes
jetzt lernen wollen
das sind tolle worte lars vielen dank
und ich glaube es ist auch sehr wichtig
dass wir jemanden für dich auch ab und
zu in der sendung haben und die
wertschätzung geben falls uns hier uns
aus der redaktion euch gegenüber ist
enorm vielen dank nochmal für diese
ausführung und schilderung und alles
gute nach hamburg vielen dank dass ich
hier sehe ich alles gute und wir
sprechen gleich mit professor ist ford
zur situation der pflege in deutschland
wollen vorher bei den blick noch mal
etwas weiter und wollen nach
skandinavien schauen genauer gesagt nach
norwegen
dort haben soziale berufe so jedenfalls
ist die gängige vorstellung einen
relativ hohen stellenwert ob dem aber
auch tatsächlich so ist und wie sich das
genau anfühlt für beschäftigte dort das
wollen wir gleich noch mal eher frage
denn meine kollegin die lacie hat eine
deutsche pflegerin befragt die seit vier
jahren in oslo lebt und dort eben auch
arbeitet alexandra bachiri arbeitet seit
circa 20 jahren auf einer
intensivstation in oslo die korona lage
auch dort angespannt was die patienten
arbeit anbelangt
ich war jetzt drei mal zeuge davon dass
ein patient gesagt hat nein ich möchte
keine hilfe mit der atmung der dann auch
relativ schnell verstorben ist und das
hängt dann an einem mehrere tage weil in
dem ausmaß haben wir das vorher halt
noch nie erlebt extreme emotionale
belastung und isolation
wie wird das vergütet in deutschland
verdienen pfleger innen durchschnittlich
3500 euro im monat
in norwegen sind es zirka 5000 euro die
arbeitsbelastung ist für alexandra
trotzdem geringer eins zu eins das heißt
ich habe nur einen patienten der
beatmung manchmal auch zwei in
deutschland zwei bis drei wir sind mehr
leute wir kriegen haben also auch mehr
hände zur verfügung
es ist mehr gehalt da und ich werde für
jede überstunde die ich mache vergütet
das war damals nicht der fall und ich
glaube auch nicht dass das
der heutige fall ist in deutschland mehr
geld aber auch hier diskutiert man ob
die arbeit von pflegekräften mehr
anerkennung braucht letztes jahr wo ja
nach der ersten welle die regierung auch
hier norwegen davon geredet habe dass
sie ihr corona kompensation bekämen oder
bekommen sollten
und dann hinterher wurde sozusagen an
unser soziales empfinden appelliert das
ja jetzt andere dinge vor der kunde
klären
da fühlt man sich veräppelt
trotz problemen in norwegen zurück nach
deutschland ist für sie keine option
einen schönen guten abend professor ist
fords schönen guten abend herr behrmann
wir haben gerade das beispiel aus
norwegen kennen gelernt auch da scheinen
die bäume nicht in den himmel zu wachsen
aber so von ihrem ersten eindruck gibt
es dinge die in norwegen besser laufen
im gesundheitssystem als bei uns na ja
es gibt schon was um die kollegin hat
das ja gesagt dass der personalschlüssel
seit langer zeit dort ein anderer ist
auch auf dem normalen stationen sie
haben jetzt zweimal beispiele aus den
intensivstationen mit in deutschland
jetzt einer neu eingeführten regelung wo
zwei patienten durch eine pflegekraft
versorgt werden und nachts sind es dann
drei patienten durch eine pflegekraft
das war in norwegen schon lange
eigentlich eins zu eins und den anderen
europäischen ländern ist es auch so aber
auch auf den normalen stationen hat eine
pflegekraft ungefähr die hälfte der
patienten zu versorgen wie das seine
deutsche pflegekraft hat das läuft das
schon anders und ich glaube ein ganz
wesentlicher teil ist dass wir insgesamt
in diesen ländern nicht nur in norwegen
auch in schweden flachere hierarchien
beobachten also das heißt pflegekräfte
sind dort gleichrangig mit ihren
pflegerischen kenntnissen angesiedelt im
team wieder das auch physiotherapeuten
und ärzte sind und das schafft ein
anderes betriebsklima also zwei
wesentliche punkte können wir vielleicht
noch mal heraus geben dass es zum einen
die bezahlung zum anderen aber auch der
betreuungsschlüssel die in norwegen im
vergleich zu deutschland insgesamt wenn
man das so pauschal sagen kann wohl
etwas besser sind für die beschäftigten
ein jahr corona aber man muss ja sagen
die bredouille oder die problematik in
der pflege gibt es schon länger also
diskussionen über zu wenig personal gab
es auch schon davor gibt es so was wie
einen webfehler im system aus ihrer
sicht haben sich lange damit beschäftigt
gibt so etwas wie eine eine grundlegende
problematik im deutschen pflegesystem ja
es gibt glaube ich mehrere problematiken
und wie immer bei komplexen problemen
kriegst du den ich einfach gelöst also
das ist natürlich das woran die politik
auch immer wieder knapp 1 einer der
wesentlichen webfehler der ist jetzt
gerade erst behoben worden
das war das mit der einführung der
fallpauschalen im krankenhaus geld
umgeleitet wurde sozusagen man hat ihm
gesagt wer bringt das geld in die
kliniken ja das sind nun mal die ärzte
und wer kostet in einer klinik geld das
sind die allen alle anderen
personalstellen das sind die
pflegekräfte das sind die therapeuten
und deswegen hat man an diesen bereichen
sehr sehr lange sehr ausgiebig gespart
um die gelder für mehr ärztliche
personal dann auch frei machen zu können
dieser webfehler hat wirklich dazu
geführt dass wir zwischenzeitlich um die
40.000 stellen weniger hatten in den
deutschen krankenhäusern als als wir das
am anfang hatten als es noch eine
personalbemessung gab
und der ist erst in den letzten jahr
aufgehoben worden das heißt es wird zeit
brauchen bis das auch wirken kann
von a bis z schreibt uns über youtube
professor ist welche möglichkeiten gibt
es kurzfristig das pflegepersonal zu
erhöhen weil backen kann man sich
natürlich nicht nein man kann es nicht
packen und ich dann auch immer wieder
davor dass wir die strategie die wir in
den letzten 15 jahren ungefähr hatten
nämlich immer die überlegung zu haben da
fehlen leute also bringen wir doch mehr
hände in die sie in das system hinein
das haben wir ganz extrem auch in der
altenpflege gesehen dass immer wieder
gesagt wird dann braucht man leute also
braucht man mehr hände
was wir aber in der pflege immer sagen
ist nein wir brauchen auch mehr köpfe
also das heißt wir brauchen gut
qualifiziertes personal ist nicht damit
geholfen wenn wir die qualifikation
senken oder weniger qualifiziertes
personal ohne ende reinbringen ins
system dh das ist kurzfristig zu machen
daher kurzfristig sind die anreize zu
geben dass die pflegekräfte die in dem
system arbeiten dort mehr aber
denn wir haben eine hohe teilzeitquote
das hat gute gründe viele sind natürlich
frauen in dem beruf und habe noch
familie haben also andere bereiche noch
zu erfüllen andere aufgaben zu erfüllen
da braucht es kluge konzepte um zum
beispiel einer mutter auch sagen zu
können pass auf ich möchte dass du von
einer 60 prozent auf eine 75 prozent
stelle rauf gehst was brauchst du dafür
welche dienstschichten kannst du machen
an welchen tagen könnten wir dich
einplanen wie könntest du das
organisieren und was können wir dafür
tun und da haben die kliniken in den
letzten jahren das angefangen zu
begreifen aber sie sind nun wirklich
noch nicht an dem punkt dass das
flächendeckend umgesetzt sei simon b hat
fragt über youtube empfehlen sie noch
die ausbildung zum pfleger ich habe sie
wie der kollege siegel auch selber
gemacht und bin auch über den auch wie
er selber auch über den zivildienst in
den pflegeberuf gegangen und auch ich
muss sagen ich hab den pflegeberuf also
das aktive im krankenhaus arbeiten nicht
verlassen weil ich dort unglücklich war
sondern einfach weil es ganz viele
weitere qualifikationsmöglichkeiten gibt
mit denen man sich auseinandersetzen
kann so bin ich schließlich irgendwann
mal an der hochschule gelandet ich kann
das uneingeschränkt weiterempfehlen weil
es schlicht und ergreifend ein sehr
erfüllender beruf ist wenn man ihnen
wenn man ihn durchführt und auf der
anderen seite bietet er eben ein
unglaublich vielfältiges
beschäftigungsfeld wir haben ja immer
vor augen das krankenhaus oder wir haben
vor augen ein altenheim aber es gibt
noch ganz viele andere betätigungsfelder
in denen pflegekräfte eigentlich aktiv
sein können und wo sie arbeiten können
in der ambulanten versorgung in den
psychiatrischen kliniken in den
rehabilitationskliniken ich selber habe
auch mal jahre auf einer
psychosomatischen station gearbeitet
also dass man all das mit einer
ausbildung machen kann so viele
verschiedene tätigkeitsfelder das ist
eigentlich einzigartig in der pflege
wunderbar professor ist wahr dass sie
heute abend auch hier uns zur verfügung
stehen denn wir haben so sehe ich das
hier eine ganze reihe von wirklich
fachkundigen fragen an sie die ich gerne
weiter gebe zum beispiel kt auch über
youtube fragt würde eine
wiedereinführung des zivil die
ist es den mitarbeitermangel in der
pflege beheben wie es da ihre
einschätzung
also den mitarbeitermangel direkt würde
ist nicht beheben aber es wäre natürlich
ein großer anreiz für männer in diesem
beruf zu gehen wir haben eine sehr
niedrige männerquote und viele der
kollegen auch aus meiner generation ich
bin 1970 geboren sind letzten endes in
die pflege gegangen weil sie gesagt
haben ich hätte niemals kontakt gehabt
zu dem system wenn ich nicht über den
zivildienst dort rein gekommen wäre
zugleich muss man eben sagen du brauchst
du schon eine bestimmte form von von
zugang zu dieser zu dieser tätigkeit
also das heißt zwangs mäßig zu sagen
alle männer sollen nach abschluss der
schule ein jahr in einem krankenhaus
arbeiten oder in einem altenheim
arbeiten das würde ich für sinnfrei
halten
auch damals gab es immer die möglichkeit
die die zur bundeswehr gehen wollten
sind zur bundeswehr gegangen und die
anderen sind eben in den zivildienst
gegangen und von denen sind auch nur ein
teil in die krankenhäuser
behinderteneinrichtungen oder in die
altenpflege einrichtungen gegangen aber
es hat tatsächlich etwas bewirkt und das
fehlt uns weiterhin und das haben die
bufdis bislang nicht auffangen können
also wäre eigentlich ein plädoyer
zumindest darüber nachzudenken wie man
an der stelle eventuell nochmal den
personalmangel bekämpfen könnte
die frage wird gestellt nach der
privatisierung von martina k über
youtube der krankenhäuser also inwieweit
ist es überhaupt sinnvoll dass
krankenhäuser das einrichtung und des
gesundheitssystems einem gewissen ja
gewinnstreben überhaupt unterliegen ist
das etwas was sie grundsätzlich
befürworten oder gibts da widerspruch da
gibt es natürlich berechtigte kritik und
berechtigten widerspruch weil die
aufgabe des gesundheitssystems nicht in
erster linie ist profit zu machen
wir haben aber das gesundheitssystem und
auch übrigens den pflegesektor also das
pflegesystem im ambulanten und teil- und
vollstationären pflege bereich darauf
ausgerichtet dass wir sagen da sollen
auch profite gemacht werden das schafft
anreize das ist das gute dabei das hat
auch in den krankenhäusern zu enormen
investitionen und auch zu enormen
arbeits veränderungen geführt die da
ohne das sicherlich nicht möglich
gewesen wären
aber man muss natürlich zugleich sehen
jetzt haben wir die geister die wir
gerufen haben und plötzlich fragen wir
uns ist das eigentlich rechtens wenn
eine französische ein französischer
investitionsfonds in deutschland
altenpflegeeinrichtungen aufkauft und
das geld in luxemburg versteuert und da
muss man natürlich sagen nein das halte
ich nicht für richtig
theresa dietrich schreibt denken sie es
liegt an der zunehmenden akademisierung
in klammern er studieren als ausbildung
dass immer weniger menschen in den
bereich der pflege einsteigen also
sicherlich ist das ein ganz wichtiger
aspekt und deswegen gibt es ja auch mit
dem neuen pflegeberufe gesetz die
möglichkeit pflege auch zu organisieren
das machen im moment aber die
wissenschaftsministerien in den ländern
viel zu zögerlich also ich glaube aus
gutem grunde wäre das natürlich eine
möglichkeit zu sagen warum denn nicht
pflege von anfang an studieren das macht
man in den meisten europäischen ländern
das macht man in großbritannien das
machte dem ganzen angloamerikanischen
raum
das macht man in so unendlich vielen
staaten und wir tun uns damit so schwer
weil wir immer denken dass sein dann
flüchtlinge auf vom bett also das heißt
sie würden sofort woanders hingehen
nur weil sie das studiert haben das
stimmt überhaupt nicht und da kann ich
nur dringend den appell an die politik
richten dass sie das wahrnehmen weil uns
gehen ansonsten natürlich möglichkeiten
verloren leute für die pflege zu
interessieren die dann sonst sagen na
dann studiere ich einen anderen bereich
und dann wird es sozialarbeiter oder
wird physiotherapeut oder studiert
irgendeine andere fachrichtung im
sozialen sektor fielen dann also das
waren jetzt ein paar allgemeine fragen
und ausführung zum thema pflege
situation in deutschland generell unser
thema ist ja eigentlich ein jahr corona
in deutschland und da vielleicht die
frage inwieweit haben sie die hoffnung
dass die probleme die jetzt auch durch
corona noch mal deutlicher geworden sind
inwieweit haben sie die hoffnung dass
das vielleicht bewirken kann dass da ein
umdenken und vielleicht auch noch mehr
hilfe seitens der politik zu erwarten
ist also auf der einen seite bin ich
immer berufsoptimist sonst würde ich das
hier nicht seit über 30 jahren
mittlerweile in der pflege machen
das heißt ich sehe schon dass auch in
den letzten jahren auch seitens der
bundesregierung viel gemacht wurde um zu
gucken was kann man in der pflege tun
die pflege hat gehör gefunden das ist
das gute und das hat sie unter corona
bedingungen auch auf der anderen seite
gibt es viele aspekte die mich
nachdenklich machen wir haben bis heute
kein monitoring in den pflegebereichen
man muss sich einfach mal vorstellen
alle reden über den sektor der
krankenhausversorgung über den sektor
der ambulanten und stationären
einrichtungen
ich sage hier nun mal das stichwort im
ins kampagnen oder wie sieht der
impfstatus von pflegekräften aus wie
sieht die bereitschaft aus und man muss
sagen das kann ihn keiner sagen weil wir
diesen bereich überhaupt nicht
systematisch beobachtet haben unter
corona und das ist etwas das mich
natürlich als schläge forscher
nachhaltig schockiert weil ich glaube
wir hätten sehr gute möglichkeiten
gehabt zu gucken was wirkt in welchen
einrichtungen welche konzepte sind gut
was können die einen von den anderen
lernen das ist versäumt worden in der
pflege man hat sich nur auf biologie auf
medizin konzentriert und hat die pflege
an der stelle vergessen
ich hoffe dass das aufgeholt wird und
ich glaube auch dass die pflege selber
sehr viel gelernt hat und auch selber
ihren ställen werden sich noch einmal
verdeutlichen konnte und das glaube ich
wird langfristig wirken weil man mit
pflegekräften wirklich auch sehr gut
umgehen muss sie sind eine unglaublich
kostbare ressource und nur wenn sie
weiterhin da sind dann können wir auch
das gesundheitssystem erhalten das ist
jedem klar geworden
wenn man jetzt mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassend also sagen auf das jahr
2021 bezogen was wären da jetzt ihre
dringendsten anliegen was sollte für die
pflege getan werden jetzt unmittelbar
sozusagen noch in der kroner zeit und
dann vielleicht auch darüber hinaus also
das eine ist natürlich die pflege
tatsächlich zuhören also nicht über die
pflege zu reden sondern mit der pflege
zu reden das ist ganz wesentlich um zu
sagen was braucht die eigentlich um
euren job zu machen
ich denke da nur am anfang an die
situation dass man
altenpflegeeinrichtungen unter kowitz
bedingungen sofort geschlossen hat und
viele pflegende und auch viele viele
pflegedienstleitungen haben gesagt das
ist wieder unsere natur wir wollen
ältere menschen nicht den kontakt
versperren
aber wir brauchen schutz bedingungen
unter denen wir das weiterhin
realisieren können und das hat nicht
stattgefunden ich hoffe dass in den
weiteren zur weiteren krisenbewältigung
vielmehr mit der pflege gesprochen wird
und das würde ich mir sehr wünschen dann
hoffen wir dass dieser appell durch
drängt wir jedenfalls werden ihn in die
welt hinaustragen vielen dank professor
soll das vom deutschen institut für
angewandte pflegeforschung in köln
komplizierter dame dankeschön dass sie
die seite hatten heute abend für uns
alles gute auch für sie danke schön
bleiben sie gesund vielen dank ich werde
mich bemühen und das gleiche gebe ich
natürlich auch an euch weiter ihr sollt
natürlich auch gesund bleiben vielen
dank für diese sehr rege beteiligung
heute gab tolle zuschriften wie ich
finde
danke noch mal dafür euch einen schönen
abend und wenn ihr mögt bis morgen